I think it's an incredibly cinematic
story that is an incredibly cinematic
treatment that Clint Eastwood have done
to it and I think the technology now is
such that I max is just bigger than life
I have an emergency he lost both engines
returning immediately the imax people
started telling me about this new camera
we went looked at it and we did tests
with it everything I found it and that's
a really good advantages this was not a
crash this was dual engine loss at a
lower altitude than any jet in history
to get up and to see the plane crash
itself and IMAX and then to get up in
the faces and see the emotion the
passage is the flight attendants to see
that water coming in I mean different
and then not only the visual but then
you have everything with imax of the
south no one has ever trained for an
incident like that hi max what's
wonderful about it is you can come
becoming completely enveloped with the
story to be kind of sucked into the
screen and feel like they're part of the
experience this is the captain
brace for him